Uh, there is no doubt that what would be best
for my show and shows like the David Pakman
show and other independent progressive media
shows would be for Donald Trump to be reelected
in November of 2020.
I mean, there's just no denying it whatsoever.
But I'm getting more and more emails from
people with these conspiratorial ideas about
how deep down I actually want Trump to win
because it would be better for my channel.
Give me a break.
Okay.
This is a show that has been my authentic
and genuine opinion about the world since
day one.
I'm not stupid or blind, right?
Like I understand every progressive show hosts
that I've spoken to understands and agrees
that we're all doing way better because Donald
Trump was elected over Hillary Clinton.
Political interest has exploded.
Donald Trump's outrageous behavior gets people
interested in the news and politics of what's
going on.
There's no question about it.
I don't know any single serious progressive
hosts who would deny that.
But do I want Donald Trump to win even if
some deep down place?
Uh, even if in some deep down place, I recognize
that he's better for my show than Hillary
Clinton.
Um, would I want him to defeat Joe Biden or
Bernie Sanders or whoever is the Democratic
nominee?
No, of course not.
And this might come as a shock to you, but
there is actually not a lot of character playing
in left wing media.
What I mean by that is on the right you have
all of these people who have had political
awakenings who just happened to be political
awakenings that move them into a lane that
is very profitable and very well funded on
the right for example.
Uh, and all of a sudden they have a whole
different variety of political views.
I know that there are or commentators on the
right who were really well funded by certain
elements of their audience to the point that
there's something called audience capture
going on and they're almost even unable to
articulate their true beliefs because they
risk jeopardizing the funding that's coming
in.
I know that that exists, that's not this show
and I don't know any progressive host of the
ones that I personally know that is doing
this sort of character playing calculation
where they say one thing on the show and really
they believe in other one behind the scenes
and in fact to a fault because it's hurt me
in many ways.
I've never modulated or modified my views
to appeal to specific slices of the audience
or whatever else, even though it would have
been particularly profitable.
So when I tell you that Trump has to go for
the betterment of our country, I mean it,
I'm not playing coy with the reality that
membership and youtube subscribers and podcast
subscribers, the whole thing has gone up way
faster under Donald Trump that under any previous
president, I'll deal with the slower growth
rate that I know will come with the removal
of Donald Trump because it's the right thing.
And it's correct.
And I will go even further.
I don't even know for sure that it's a drastic
difference at this point in time.
Yes.
If Hillary had defeated Trump, things would
have been much more boring.
Political interest would have been significantly
lower than it is.
But now that we've had Trump, I expect that
if Trump loses in 2020, he'll lose his mind.
Even with a Democratic president, there will
be, uh, years of crazy stuff going on.
And also I believe that Donald Trump's presidency
has had a sort of irreversible change to American
politics that has been caused and things are
going to be wacky and interesting for a long
time.
So I'm also not even really worried that the
growth rate will be significantly lower if
Donald Trump loses.
So accuse me of something reasonable, you
know, telling me my conclusions about taxation
or wrong telling me my foreign policy views
are missing something, but telling me I actually
want Trump to win because he's been good for
the show.
Give me a break, don't waste your time, don't
waste my time with that nonsense.